hello everyone I hope you enjoyed my
previous video on the Halloween gambit
because this video is about the
Halloween gambit as well it's also
played by Google moonship the same guy
from the previous video but this game
he's playing against the V velop I was
also played in 1994 and well this is the
switched-off students tournament and his
opponent decided to play a bit
differently than mr. Petrov from the
previous video so let's see how to
handle and the Halloween gambit when
black decides to defend differently we
have E 4 E 5 ninth to f3 Knight to f6
Knight c3 and knight c6 so the four
Knights game and like we explained the
white has a ton of options here
but there is one special that is not in
Knight captures on e5 and this is the
Halloween gambit Knight captures on e5
we have d4 as in the previous video
Knight to c6
now d5 Knight to e5 now f4 everything is
the same as in the previous video nice
to g6 we have E 5 Knight 2 g8 d 6 C
captures on d6 and E capture son d6 and
this is the exact same position from the
previous video where mr. Petrov played
Queen to f6 but here mr. velov plays
Queen to a5 he takes a different
approach to try and defend we have page
4 by MintChip now Queen to b4
adding pressure to this d6 pawn and the
Queen to e2 with check we have King to
d8 and now f5 attacking that night on g6
we have Knight captures on h4 and we
have h 3s or a3
now trying to kick the Queen away from
the defense of the night on a 4 if Queen
to d4 then Bishop to e3 again gains the
temple on the Queen
so unlike in the previous video black
decides to give back the piece much
sooner
so Knight captures on g2 with check we
have Bishop Queen captures on g2 and now
Queen captures this pawn on d6 and it
seems like black managed to defend his
position we have Bishop to d2 and now
Queen to e5
check this is a well you're so much
underdeveloped and black should
definitely go for moves like Knight to
f6 or something to try and develop his
pieces but he plays Queen - if I would
check
we have Bishop to e2 and now again a
nice to f6 or any kind of development is
better than what black played a black
played Queen captures on f5 so grabbing
a pawn and what you do have now black is
up three pawns but his King is on the
eight this Bishop cannot come into the
game both rooks cannot be developed and
well I moonlight Knight to f6 was
definitely preferred so we have a
queenside castle by mr. Minch eV and
Queen to g6 now again playing with the
Queen and well black is up three pawns
and he would definitely like to exchange
Queens which is not in White's favor
white would probably want to play
something like Quinta f3 Queen - f -
maybe queen - H - as white white is well
every White's piece is developed and he
should definitely keep the Queen's on
the board but the white gets a different
idea and he plays Queen captures on g6
this pawn is pinned so H captures and g6
isn't really possible F captors and g6
was played and now Knight to b5 and the
knight isn't really doing anything and
b5 it's just there you know making his
presence known and black totally
disregards this he plays Knight to f6
and the white plays Bishop to f4 and
night this night the c7 or Bishop to c7
isn't really much of a threat but as
this is the Halloween gambit black
probably got a little bit scared and he
played Knight to e8 trying to defend the
c7 square although he's defending it for
no reason
Bishop to e3 and this is something
you'll often see in games which were the
Halloween gambit was used where the
player with the black pieces doesn't
really handle the position - well he
plays a6 and again I move like nice to
f6 or d6 was preferred
but weaker players will tend to play a
move like a six that protect the a seven
pawn and this allows black a beautiful
beautiful King hunt Bishop to b6 with
check we have King to e7 and black
probably thought that well I'm attacking
his an item B 5 after the knight moves I
will consolidate with the d6 or maybe
came to f7 and get my pieces into the
game but mr. min Chavez he is such a
Halloween gambit expert thought about
this and he played rook ht1 giving up
the knight on d5 for for a nice
discovered to check we have a captures
knight on d5 and now Bishop the c-4
check and now this bishop is covering
the 8 this bishop is covering f7 this
rope is covering the entire defiled this
rook is covering the entire efile so
there is only one move available to the
black king that is King to f6 and well
it's very unfortunate because with best
defense is checkmate in 7 moves and so
the King hunt begins we have King to
have six and now Bishop the d8 with
check King has to go deeper into the
position King to f5 we have ripped the
d5 check and now black has the option of
going rogue to f4 or rock the g4 sorry
came to a fork into g4 and if King to f4
which was played in the game it's making
four moves but let's just check what
happens if came to g4 if came to g4 then
rook to d4 check King to h3 rook to e3
check King to G G 2 and now Rock the D
to check if King to h1 and rook to e1
check that's checkmate unfortunately for
black but in the in the game after up to
d5 check King to f4 was played and well
disallowed a much more elegant
checkmate we have worked the d4 with
check King to g3 and now Bishop to h4
would check why not bring the the bishop
into the game to have some fun King to
h2 and now a silent but a deadly move
Bishop to b5 and there is no defense
against rock - h1 checkmate but black to
decided
to play this game on and he played
Bishop to c5 although it doesn't really
matter what move he plays Bishop to c5
and now rook to h1 checkmate and again
mr. Gregor Mincha created a beautiful
Halloween gambit King Hunt masterpiece
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed this to Halloween gambit games
one was a pretty swift victory for mr.
Minch EV the other one was a it was a
very nice King Hunt I don't believe I'll
I'll be featuring anymore Halloween
games on my channel maybe until next
Halloween so I do hope you enjoyed it
and well like I said in my sorry like I
said in my previous video for those of
you who enjoy such things have a happy
Halloween and have a good time as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank y'all for watching and I will
see you soon